[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
former dallas cop amber geiger argues
her murder conviction should be
overturned
in the shooting of her neighbor botham
john i acknowledge that she intended to
kill because that's what she testified
and wife killer scott peterson inches
closer to getting a new hearing
in his death colony case plus real
estate air robert durst
wants his trial for the murder of his
best friend delayed as his attorneys say
their client plans to take the stand
and the independent autopsy of andrew
brown jr released
by his family the north carolina
sheriff's response to calls for release
of body cam footage
in the fatal shooting by deputies body
cameras are shaky
and sometimes hard to decipher plus our
investigation continues into the
massacre of an ohio family of eight
the new information prosecutors are
revealing as one man agrees to testify
against his family
over a deadly custody battle it just
chills you to think about
the calculation that goes into something
like this
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a former texas police officer is
appealing her conviction and sentence
for the fatal shooting of her neighbor
in his own home
a dallas jury found amber geiger guilty
of murdering botham john
john was sitting in his apartment when
geiger entered and pulled the trigger
murdering him she took the stand in her
own defense and told the jury she
thought she was in her own apartment
geiger was sentenced at 10 years and
john's brother hugged her
in an emotional courtroom moment but
geiger's defense now says the evidence
was insufficient to support murder
and is asking the court of appeals to
overturn the murder charge and sentence
her to a lesser felony
how she was able to enter the apartment
how she's able to
access an apartment that doesn't belong
to her the problems that
ranger armstrong discussed that was with
the strike plate
uh on the deadbolt you know it turns out
that mr jean's
door wasn't even locked properly um mr
moly you're overlooking the fact that
miss geiger testified that she
intentionally shot mr jean
i'm not overlooking the fact your honor
i agree
she did intentionally shoot mr jean
because that was
her intent that was the truth those were
the facts of the case
if she had walked into her apartment
and there was an intruder inside her
apartment she would have been entitled
to use deadly force and self-defense
her defense then went on to argue that
if she is guilty
she should only be found guilty of the
lesser included negligent homicide
intentionally or knowingly killing
another human is an evil act
okay that's what she was convicted of
the problem is that when she entered
what she thought was her own apartment
she did not have evil intent when she
entered her own apartment
you know merely you know again just
because of her alleged
mistaken belief about where she was
doesn't negate her intent to kill
but it your honor it negates my argument
as it negates
the mens rea and negates the evil intent
okay because you know we wouldn't be
here talking about this if she had
walked into
her own apartment okay so she walks into
her own apartment
and she shoots and kills an intruder
here she walked into the wrong apartment
and in these horrific set of facts she
shot and killed mr jean
the only difference between those two
scenarios
is her mistaken belief about where she
was was that mistaken belief
reasonable under the circumstances
say geiger murdered both of jean and her
conviction and sentence should stand
this is a murder case not a criminal
trespass case
when amber geiger shot both of john she
didn't take someone else's property
she took the life of a human being she
took allison and bertram's son
she took brant and alyssa's brother she
took alexis stossel's friend
she took joshua brown's neighbor she
didn't make a mistake about that
she knew botham was a living human being
she pointed a gun at him
she intended to kill him that's murder
it's not negligent it's not mistake of
fact
it's not justified amber geiger murdered
beatham john
this court should say so and affirm the
trial court's judgment
one by one the prosecutor struck down
the defendant's arguments
saying geiger does not have a
self-defense claim
the only evidence of self-defense in
this case came from appellant's
testimony
she said that she believed botham was in
her apartment
that she commanded him to show his hands
and he didn't
and that he quickly moved toward her
while saying hey hey
but the jury can disbelieve any or all
of a witness's testimony
and if the jury didn't believe
appellant's testimony then there's no
other
evidence of self-defense much less
insufficient to reject self-defense
and all the other evidence in the case
contradicted appellant's testimony
no one heard her give commands to show
hands
both of them didn't have pockets where
he could have hidden his hands
the trajectory of the gunshot wound
means that he wasn't
quickly moving toward her and no
reasonable person
would have mistaken botham's apartment
with the red doormat
the backlit room number the flashing red
light on the lock
and the marijuana smell as her own
joining us is journalist and true crime
analyst pat lalama
along with terry austin pat amber geiger
has already served about 18 months
if her appeal is successful she could be
released with what many call time served
what are your thoughts on that
well if we're overturning the conviction
and reducing it
or at least reducing that conviction to
negligence on the side
that's a two year sentence that's a big
difference for a young woman it's a big
difference for anyone
but here at the woman who does not want
to be incarcerated and
i think the only thing i would say is
why didn't she ask for backup
why didn't she administer aid you know
there's a lot of complexities here
and it's going to be up to that panel to
figure it out but there are still so
many questions
absolutely now terry overturning an
appeal is a high hurdle to overcome
do you see this appeal being successful
i don't think it's going to be
successful brian if you listen to that
argument
the judges were really pounding in on
geiger's attorney
and asking him multiple questions and
saying basically
that the conviction of murder was
correct he was trying to argue
that the evidence did not support a
murder charge he was stating
that it was quite reasonable that she
would mistaken
his apartment for her apartment and that
many people had
done that in the past and they even had
a lawyer who was on the stand who lived
in the building
but none of that really makes any
difference because ultimately
she was on the stand and she herself
said
i intended to kill him so i think that
was very difficult
for the jury to overlook and that does
support
a murder charge yeah that testimony from
her is going to be very hard
to overcome absolutely agree thank you
both still ahead on law and crime daily
will real estate heir robert durst take
the stand at his upcoming trial in the
murder of his best friend
but first scott peterson might soon be
given a new trial
after the killings of his own of his
wife and unborn son we will tell you why
coming up
[Music]
welcome back convicted killer scott
peterson is one step closer to getting a
retrial of his death penalty case
peterson was found guilty in 2004 for
the murder of his wife lacey
and unborn son connor in december 2002.
he was sentenced to death but california
supreme court recently tossed it out
and ordered he received a new penalty
phase of his trial
the high court ruled that potential
jurors were excused from the jury pool
when they expressed they were opposed to
the death penalty peterson appeared in
court via zoom on tuesday
saying few words his defense is also
requesting a new trial for the murder
charges
arguing a juror lied during pre-trial
questioning he's due back in court
in june back with us as journalists and
true crime analysts pat lalama
as well as terry austin pat you've been
following peterson's case since the very
beginning can you
tell us a little bit more about the
defense's arguments well today we're
doing the power of the appellate
attorney right i mean
we're really using the full force of
what the law allows
from these situations having said that i
am shocked to be looking at him again
after all these years but his attorney
pat harris
uh really feels that he has a chance for
a new trial
in that uh journal
[Music]
number i'm going to say allegedly why
when asked about having any police
connections or involvement
and the fact was that she had filed
harassment uh
uh documents because of an ex
who she felt was putting her life in
danger that's a specific
i mean that's pretty that's pretty heavy
duty but at the same time
are they going to decide that everything
would have been different
based on that one lie and i think that's
where you attorneys know better than me
but i'm i'm stunned i don't know if
there's going to be my guess would be
that
he's not going to win on that one but i
can't say absolutely
let's ask terry terry prosecutors often
win these appeals
do you think that the evidence could
outweigh any potential error i often
think of harmless error when it comes to
this appeal
you know on the penalty portion of the
case brian i think that
if the judge in fact excluded certain
jurors because of their view on the
death penalty
then we will likely see a new penalty
phase on the trial portion
i don't think we're going to see a new
trial because in fact
even if there were a juror who said that
they excluded certain evidence that was
minor and i don't think it will have an
effect on the
ultimate outcome of the trial and i
don't think that we'll get a new trial
because of that very issue
i tend to agree but of course whether or
not there's a new trial or new penalty
phase will definitely keep you
up to date on that also in california
the murder trial of robert durst is set
to restart on may 17
but not without an appeal from his
defense team
the new york real estate air is accused
of killing his best friend susan berman
in her los angeles home in december
2000. durst trial had three days of
openings and 10 witnesses take the stand
before coven 19 postponed the trial on
march 12
2020. the defense is claiming the 14
month long adjournment is unreasonable
and unprecedented
the appeal went on to cite the 14th
amendment calling for due process in a
jury
who has been untainted by a delay in
outside influences
the 78-year-old is also suspected of
killing his wife kathleen
in the 1980s in 2001 durst was tried and
acquitted of shooting and killing his
neighbor
morris black in texas he pled guilty to
evidence tampering for dismembering
black's body
terry at the heart of this appeal is a
14-month delay what if the jurors say
hey i was watching terry austin or
pat lallama could that be a possible
reason for an appeal to win
absolutely i cannot even believe that
we've had this 14-month delay you know a
defendant is entitled under the
constitution
to a trial and to a fair and impartial
trial
and this is not fair and impartial as
much as i think that
the defendant is guilty here no question
about that in my view based on what i've
seen so far the
evidence i do think that it is not
fair to have a juror sit for that long
and expect after
this number of months to remember what
happened how are they possibly
going to get their recollection
refreshed and is that
even fair to the defendant so i think we
could very well get a mistrial here and
start all over as
it should be done now pat you were there
before the pandemic stopped this case
and you're planning on being back there
as well
with us what do you think of this
potential that durst could potentially
testify
well that is the big carrot they keep
dangling in front of us and they told us
in the beginning that he would
and then they walked it back a little
bit and now
the feeling is that he will and i'll be
honest with you because i speak to his
attorney victor garan quite
often and did so today for this show uh
i think the feeling is what has he got
to lose
he is not
[Music]
well physically physically he's
not doing well and i think his feeling
is what the heck why not
you know what's the worst that can
happen in their own words he says
i'm either going to die in prison or i'm
going to die in some little folks home
so he sort of has this fatalistic
attitude
i will say one thing viktor garan did
going back to the issue of this jury
he is very concerned about the welfare
of the jurors because
as he mentioned and rightfully so we've
all as human beings
been changed by coping
i'm not the same person i was a year ago
and who knows how many of these jurors
may have
family issues or financial issues or
just stress
issues and he wants the ability to talk
to all the jurors and that hasn't been
set yet so i'm sorry for going back to
the original
uh comment but i just wanted to get that
in there you can pick up a lot of great
points void deer could be something that
they try to do to kind of
uh cure any potential issues but we'll
wait to see how that plays out
coming up on law and crime daily one man
is pleading guilty to ohio's largest
murder mystery
but others are still awaiting trial the
shocking new evidence
you don't want to miss plus andrew brown
jr's family is looking for answers
the result of their independent autopsy
the finding of the 42 year old shot five
times by deputies
next
[Music]
we're back the family of a north
carolina man killed by deputies
say their independent autopsy shows he
was shot five times including once
at the back near his neck
andrew brown jr was killed as deputies
in elizabeth city attempted to serve him
with an arrest warrant last week
brown's family says he was shot four
times in the arm before officers fired
the fatal shot
near the base of his neck his family and
attorney was able to view a redacted
portion of the sheriff's office
body cam footage on monday the sheriff
says he supports a public release
of the video we also allowed the family
of mr brown
and his attorney to privately view the
video
this tragic incident was quick and over
in less than 30 seconds
and body cameras are shaky and sometimes
hard to decipher
they only tell part of the story
outside investigators both from the sbi
and from four other sheriff's offices
are interviewing witnesses and gathering
more information
back with us is journalist and true
crime analyst pat lalama
and co-host terry austin pat what do you
make of releasing only 20 seconds
of the body cam video well
you know there are there are strong
protocols in each department in fact
this is the root of all the argument
about police body camps
and i i've gone through it cover all of
it in
major cities particularly here in los
angeles and the issue is
you know who has the right to that
footage do the cops
uh have an obligation to release it
immediately
and one thing that a lot of sheriffs and
police chiefs have told me is
as this gentleman said the the video
doesn't
always tell the whole story and while it
creates a lot of emotion
and it can be very damning and
appropriately so it can also be
exculpatory and there are also a lot of
angles we don't know about
this apparently was shaky and a lot of
things were undecipherable so i think we
have to be very
careful about how we let a piece of
footage
define
[Music]
absolutely now terry it comes to mind
because it just happened
uh a week ago on the heels of a derrick
chauvin conviction where the volume of
video
is so helpful for the prosecution and
finding justice for many people
uh what do you make of the lack of video
being released here
you know body cam video is so critical
brian we're seeing that
even on a national level with the george
floyd policing act
it's necessary to see what actually
happened and in all of these other cases
especially in the george floyd derek
chovin trial
we saw that that video was important but
it's important in all of these cases
whether it's
dante wright adam toledo whether it's
you know
andrew brown here we need to see what
exactly happened
and i think the fact that the police was
hesitant
is not a good you know position to be in
yeah it's one thing to have the body cam
videos but the question becomes when you
have them
what are you going to do with the video
and we're going to find out how that
plays out here
thank you both when we come back an ohio
man turning on his own family
as they await trial in the murder of
eight people why the prosecutors say
there's even more shocking evidence
still ahead
[Music]
welcome back we're learning more about
the family at the center of ohio's pike
county massacre
and how they operated law and crime's
angelette levy shows us what other acts
prosecutors say support their case for
murder
jake wagner pleaded guilty to 23 charges
including eight counts of aggravated
murder
in the deaths of his ex-girlfriend and
her family
prosecutors say the wagners lived an
insular life focused on control of
children
and the young women who entered their
lives i am guilty
28 year old jake wagner admitted he and
his family plotted and planned for
months
to murder hannah mae rhoden and any
members of her family who stood in the
way of jake getting sole custody of
their daughter
the defendant has in essence confessed
and apologized for committing these
offenses
with his family members and admits to
personally causing the death
of five of the eight victims a notice
from prosecutors to introduce other acts
evidence claims jake wagner assaulted
controlled chased and threatened to kill
hannah rhoden during their relationship
and put her body where it would never be
found prosecutors make similar claims
against the wagners involving jake's
older brother george
and his ex-wife and their son the
prosecutor wrote that the wagners got
the woman to sign away
almost all of her custody rights under
false pretenses
and then kept the child from her the
murders in april 2016 were shocking
eight members of the rhoden family shot
in the head as they slept in four
locations
when the wagners moved to alaska in 2017
jake wagner married a young woman court
documents say the wagners threatened to
kill the woman and became upset
when jake's daughter started referring
to her as mom
we're fully satisfied that he's gone
eyes wide open into
this agreement he knows he's going to
die in prison
without any judicial release part of the
plea agreement for jake wagner
included taking the death penalty off
the table for his mom his father
and his older brother george george
wagner is expected in pike county court
this week
for a motion hearing for law and crime
daily
i'm angenette levy thanks annette let's
bring pat and tyrion one last time
pat kind of sounds like he might be
trying to save his family but as our
resident true crime analyst what do you
make of this plea deal
and where should we be looking next in
this case
well you know first of all what a
horrible thing that happened in my home
state of
ohio and i it is so hard for me after
all the crime i've covered in 42 years
to imagine wiping out a couple of
families over a
custody battle among that that
was emerging among all of these people i
don't
i'm not convinced it was just custody at
the same time it looks like
you know in his mind um
he wants to save his own life but he
also wants to save the lives of his
family
yet this will force him to basically rap
them out so
i don't have i don't know what else to
make of it except it's going to be
interesting to watch what happens
uh with this feud absolutely terry do
you think we should be expecting more
families to start taking pleas with
similar deals
or maybe not let's hope not brian
because this crime was so heinous too
many people
obviously were killed in one family and
the fact that they don't have the death
penalty
that should be enough i think we should
prosecute them to the fullest extent
and call it a day all right thanks for
joining us here at long crime daily
we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you